vocês sabiam que 95% dos casamentos no
brasil ainda são alvo de alguns cidadãos
surpreender vocês pensem que isso não é
só no brasil isso é uma realidade em
todo mundo a gente ainda tem porcentual
acima da quase 90% de casamentos que são
arranjados
eu não tô falando aqui o casamento
matrimonial ou de duas resoluções de
nações duas pessoas adultas protocolando
no casamento entre o estudante e
aprendizagem ou entre as pessoas e
aprendizagem analisar uma unidade
evoluir nessa questão das relações no
passado
se vocês tivessem que vocês não tivessem
escolhido que tivesse sido direcionado
às crianças e adolescentes que fora
sendo casado com conteúdos e
conhecimentos que eles não se
apaixonarem que não chama a atenção
deles que não é algo que foi uma escolha
deles mas sim de algo que o nosso
sistema impõe assim ultimamente com o
sistema trazia a relação entre as
pessoas com ovos escolhido por outros
tantos de vocês no seu processo
educativo não gostava
se vocês fizeram e aprender como seria
diferente se ao inverno nós temos que
fazer todos da mesma forma nós
pudéssemos escolher aquilo que a gente
chamasse estudar é um conceito que se
chama educação personalizada
se tem uma bandeira disso eu vou fazer
analisada num sistema que não me permite
e escolher o que eu quero estudar pouco
quem eu quero casar com alguém que eu
sinto que essa pessoa é a pessoa que eu
escolhi pra mim interessa você vai
querer saber mais o elegeu como seria se
o aluno pudesse se apaixonar com
conteúdo e se destinar mais daqui
certamente algumas pessoas diriam você
tem muita coisa que precisa saber que
não vai fazer de quando você está numa
relação entre duas pessoas presentes o
dia cunhados e por aí vai
com isso diversas coisas lindas sobre
pessoas que forma isso e vai descobrindo
essa aqui eu gostei
na minha vida que eu cobrei dele isso
pode ser feito com o conteúdo eu posso
eu posso ter uma um conteúdo uma
condição a long e eu me apaixonei por
uma determinada experiência que eu vivi
no processo a união e submetido a um ato
i que é o solo tem uma placa que me
permite entender como a física funciona
pra entender esse processo houve
conhecimento estão dentro dele como
apaixonam desse conhecimento e o que eu
quero é totalmente diferente ea muda o
conceito ela muda forma modificação
acontece agora a relação e o professor
em seu processo de aprendizagem
o seu processo de aprendizado nós
queremos que uma escola muito nós
queremos que o processo de educação
mundo mas os professores só conhecem
casamento arranjado por quê porque
aprenderam dessa forma eles aprendendo
com alguém quando estava em segundo eles
a mataram esse número chamado uma
situação que era arranjado
eles não sabem fazer diferente do que a
gente precisa fazer a gente precisa
mudar esse processo a gente precisa
mudar nossa forma de olhar o dia com a
família em agosto ele quita ela teve que
passar por todos os conceitos da
inovação por todos vocês não imaginam a
gente poder fazer a nossa vida a gente
tem filhos que são diferentes
a gente não consegue educar os filhos da
mesma forma
aquela diversão diz assim mas eu tanto
os filhos exatamente da mesma forma e
eles acham que eu valorizo diferente
porque porque as pessoas são diferentes
elas querem ser tratadas diferente eu
trabalho a ascensão de diferença
significa valorizar sua cidade de hama e
estar tratando ela com a mesma mesmo
[Música]
fazer um processo de chamar trilha de
aprendizagem
eu pude ter caminhos diferentes para me
levar o meu ano nesse processo
se nós começarmos lugar pra isso não
adianta sonhar
a mudança não vai acontecer e
aprendizagem a gente não vai falando
apenas em sala de aula a gente está
falando de aprendizagem pra vida
nós estamos vivendo um momento onde a
gente aprenda todo dia e não só uma
pergunta vocês pensem nisso quando foi
um momento que vocês aprenderam uma
coisa nova
eu pergunto isso todo dia e eu continuo
a minha que me sinto frustrada o dito
não consigo aprender uma coisa nova
porque o nosso taco criando incluindo
justamente pela capacidade que a gente
tem de peso lançar de pequenas de co
criar e aprender e isso é pra vida
nós fizemos planos nós fizemos projetos
pra gente crescer podem casar pode ter
filhos
para isso pra esse conceito da educação
personalizada da trilha
o deságio a gente leva os alunos da
educação projetos que essa questão de
projetar a vida
isso vai dar uma mudança significativa o
que eu quero deixar claro aqui aqui uma
junta essa mudança partiu das escolas
porque a nossa sociedade está pronto
para receber isso infelizmente muitos
pais querem o que um casamento mas já
com os seus filhos com o enem vestibular
e que aquele conteúdo que está pronta e
não um projeto de vida que faz com que
eles descumpram nos seus filhos no seu
talento
faço algumas telhas dançar com
conhecimento e se a mulher do carro
transe e nós precisamos hackear esse
processo em conjunto as pessoas
as escolas os professores e os
estudantes reconectar a educação com o
processo de aprendizagem
ele poderá usar muito daqui eu usar as
tecnologias de conectar é despertar a
criatividade nice s
nós não vamos mudar nada
se as pessoas vão trabalhar a educação
com visão diferente e se nós não fomos
criativos a criatividade e presunto uma
coisa muito importante que é a educação
que são as competências emocionais e eu
não me envolvo isso seu condiciona as
pessoas a seguirem algo que está pré
estabelecido
eu não desenvolva uma capacidade de uma
pessoa à margem de uma forma diferente
algo que ela foi condicionado e escolhi
aqui no brasil eu preciso ter essa
criatividade
então o convite é que pra mim possa
fazer essa mudança nos
acreditar que o pai mãe que olhe pra
isso a escola não conseguir seu aluno
viseu filho a descobriu seu talento a se
conectar com a sua essência e fazer com
que isso realmente a que hora não sabia
que ele quer e se conecta com isso ele
vai aprender isso muitas vezes as
crianças têm hoje capacidade além
daquele conhecimento que está lá muito
nele e vocês também eo convite é para
que vocês coloquem o momento é de vocês
aprender a cada dia uma coisa nova esse
é um passo pra gente poder recolher está
assim a educação aprendizagem porque
enquanto professora não brilha aprender
ea gente não possibilitava aí nos
processos de capacitação dele que tem
ficado aumento diferenciado não saber
nós não vamos fazer mudanças e enquanto
os pais e os próprios adolescentes nós
não nos apaixonarmos por essa visão
diferente da aprendizagem
a gente não tem no total a obra já dizia
às pessoas decentes em qualquer coisa
preciso ser especialista da vida e
inspirador de sugestões
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]